thank you
it was an emotional evening for Demar
Hamlin after he received a standing
ovation at the 2023 ESPYs on Wednesday
night while presenting this year's Pat
Tillman award for service to the Buffalo
Bills training staff but before the
ceremony the 25 year old shared what it
meant to him to be able to recognize
their heroic life-saving actions they
wake up every day with not wanting any
credit for doing what they do they just
show up to do the job you know to the to
the perfect way and that's what happened
in my situation so you know for them to
be on this stay big stage like
this and get the recognition that they
deserve for you know saving their life
yeah for sure in front of the entire
world and how much does it mean to you
to be here with them as well it means
everything you know we shared a special
moment together you know we're bonded
together for life no matter if I'm on
the Buffalo Bills for a thousand more
years or what you know we'll I'll be
bonded with that medical staff for life
you know so um you know they're like
family wow so powerful and things
quickly got emotional for Demar as he
welcomed the training team on stage
please welcome this year's recipient of
the Pat Tillman award for service the
training staff of the Buffalo Bills
[Applause]
[Music]
while accepting the award on behalf of
the entire training team head athletic
trainer Nate breske shared a heartfelt
moment with DeMar
DeMar
first and foremost
thank you for staying alive brother
thank you
[Music]
seriously we are so honored
to be standing up here next to such a
strong and courageous human being
back in January during a game against
the Cincinnati Bengals Hamlin collided
with Bengals wide receiver T Higgins and
immediately collapsed after receiving
CPR from assistant athletic trainer
Denny Kellington Demar was taken off the
field by ambulance Hamlin remained in
critical condition for an extended
amount of time and according to his
uncle had to be resuscitated twice
four days after his Cardiac Arrest
episode Hamlin woke up and was able to
communicate and immediately asked if the
bills had won the game we don't know of
course the extent of his injuries but
the entire Bill's team is out on the
field right now and in his first
interview after the terrifying incident
Hamlin spoke with Good Morning America
co-anchor and former NFL pro Michael
Strahan about his remarkable recovery I
owe Denny my life literally you know him
just just you know he loves to say he
was just doing his job but and which is
true that night he was literally the
savior of my life you know
administrating CPR on me and that's
something I'm I'm truly thankful for and
I don't take for granted